2ヶ月ぶりに酒造家に帰ってきた肇社長だったら俺のいえば大きく荒れ果てていたね
ヶ月かも1 y 4放置すると部屋が荒れてしまい廃墟と化してしまう俺の予想が
正しければこの近場とてをとても汚いはずだ
ね汚いよねー
3カ月間汚い部屋放置するとどうなっていたかちょっと重く帰って来て初めには地下に
行くんで見ていこうと思います動きをいた瞬間俺もう帰るよ
ぶっちゃけ茎弁財んだけど耐えな気がすんだよなっています
[音楽]
ところてんやリア
屋根東京行く前に掃除したんですけど総勢したものを捨てる時間がなくてそれをズーム
近いにまとめて置いてたんでいます凄いことになってますよちょっとみよっ
[音楽]
すごい様です2ネイティブ理想なんだけどもできる力動画で使わなくなった物とかいら
ないものをポイポイポイってってことなんですっげーダンボールとかいろんなものが
あるんですけども濃昼出る瞬間も俺終わりだかっ
8ちょっとカメラマンお願い絶対いるでしょこのでベルドゥ
可能絶対発生それ
て階です
えってかこれ誰の子道土なものが増えるんです
余り物も十分ですね
これこいつらない頑丈すぎんこれってどれだけロット
[音楽]
う n
うっん
マッハ
ああああああ
これどうやってこれを解き放ってさあちょっと1回中身だけ見ていますよね
俺本当に知らないもするないんでしょじゃないですか
ブーバこれはえーっ
ボックスウオッチャーロス
なにこれえっ
ええええええ
なにこれ
考えネットっぽく鉄の塊でこっち
もうどう開けたらいいかわかんないんだよなぁどうアッパーでもこっちに切り口がある
これん
こっちだな切り口があるからいいます
ん
ほほーっ
バスじゃねっ
芦田に足だわー
cf 2
そのホロホロホロ姉さんラバーがいい
裏は今は4本だってっぽされないえっさんって言うんですか
バーン前に加えからということはこっちが馬鹿を見るって事ドラなってきたでこういう
展開でまったりだ
バーン
はいじゃあまずはこれ
ハーイハーイハーイ
バッハ angeln
できます
持っていた
うーんまずでこれやばいべよ
おおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおお
いきます
教え航空群増えできます
ああああああ
ですピッえっ本当わーっ
事件の香りがする混ぜて釣っ
先生はえっ打つ0でパンジャパなかなかちもんな
さああああ
ます
b 4
t 4
ああああああ
あって怖いよで狩る4をデイジイサンブレがありません
綺麗なんでありますよ鳥飼かんだ
ran
ウッホスンドア